[Musique]
c'est apparemment veut c'est que ce
moment je le rate est sympa
c'est tranquille
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
marine
qu'est ce que je t'ai déjà dit à propos
des retards excusez moi madame tu as de
la chance que je sois bonne humeur la
prochaine fois c'est l'heure de colle la
tuque à l'état soir boîte à la lame
travaux non mais c'est quoi ce bazar
[Musique]
le
où
[Musique]
oh
on
tout ça s'arrête so you
qu'est ce qu'il ya l'attention
d'investisseurs collègues et moi jamais
vu coller le collège et je peux t'aider
stylo ne les gagnera tous
impressionnants si tu pouvais changer
les choses tu cherches quoi vont jamais
changée par la violence non pas l'examen
s'était jamais dit que pour être aussi
en colère et flotte elle aussi elle
devait vivre de la colère de la violence
ni au point que moon in a fait un jeune
homme pâle exactement pas les témoins
président à z tout et non pas les docks
sapant problème faire part aux familles
de la soul et ainsi ne connaît même pas
ou peu près une oryem que nous même pas
[Musique]
moore
on
alors on espère d'un débile nous voici
sa voix si cartonne en poste sera ne
s'affaiblit comme l'an passé déjà nantis
[Musique]
ces paniers marginaux dont stella artois
et amouda et rempiler à la tête coiffée
ça s'appelle débit largement copine
[Musique]
alex nadeau à date ça
de manet nouveau mission ne l'avait pas
défini on saura au trop bien m a besoin
d'un jour elle n'était pas mon avocat me
gêne pas apparemment ce départ howden de
malhao vient ici même sous la fine va
faire question juan vargas est tout seul
compris et oublie pas le code
[Musique]
emilie arrêté passage qu'aux photos
nikon est tout ému à dos santos 20 ans
note tout problème des solutions sous
faisalabad en sachant la retient notre
moules ou tissu osseux rares malheureuse
et la samain ne me laisse pas au mieux à
dos
j'ai bien entendu secours à vidy la
situation paraît assez grave
vous avez eu beaucoup de courage de
venir vous avez bien fait de venir en
parler j'ai bien compris que
toi tu étais en souffrance que toi tu
accompagné d'un camarade ce qu'on va
faire dans un premier temps c'est vous
allez rencontrer l'infirmière et
l'assistante sociale pour en parler
davantage
et dans un deuxième temps nous
informerons la police ce qui s'est passé
est très grave je le rappelle je vous le
redis
vous avez eu beaucoup de courage pour en
parler un début de solution c'est d'en
parler
donc merci à vous et merci à toi d'avoir
accompagné d'un camarade
voilà ma seconde et bilal au québec sera
finistère et avis parce que c'est un bad
boys
bon
[Musique]
ses causes et effets d'un bureau pense
pas je garde pas au sol
[Musique]
mais pourtant j'étais sûr
e
oh
où
[Musique]
oh